non
[Musique]
les procureurs de 48 états américains et
le bureau américain de la concurrence
porte des accusations contre facebook
pour abus de position dominante les
pratiques anticoncurrentielles ils
veulent réduire la puissance de facebook
est obligé l'entreprise à vendre ses
services
instagram et whatsapp faut-il cassé
démanteler facebook avec nous ce soir
des stratèges en communication numérique
nelly brière et bruno guglielminetti
bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir nelly brière est-ce qu'il faut
casser le modèle facebook
ben non en fait ça pour moi ça ne fait
aucun sens ce qui est demandé à facebook
c'est même dans la pratique je vois pas
comment ça peut être chez techniquement
ok bon ça c'est votre première réponse
mais je vais laisser répondre nous
également
est-ce qu'il faut casser le modèle
facebook bruno ben écoutez je pense que
ça prendrait une petite période
d'adaptation mais j'ai l'impression que
les trois réseaux pourrait fonctionner
quand même
parallèlement dans des colonnes bien
différent les trois réseaux vous voulez
dire quoi parce que dira facebook
instagram et moi tiens mais et donc on
pourrait les diviser autrement dit forcé
facebook avant d'instagram et what's up
tout à fait comme on l'a déjà fait dans
d'autres industries
dans ce cas ci il faut se rappeler
qu'avant d'être intégré à facebook
elles étaient trois services distincts
ouais par la suite on a harmonisé on
arts mélangés tout ça mais techniquement
ça peut se faire qu on peut on peut
refaire trois réseaux distincts ok et
vous pensez nelly qu'on devrait pas
faire ça dites nous pourquoi mais moi je
ne pense pas que ça se peut déjà ça
serait très complexe dont tout d'abord
c'est un peu il ya un premier problème
c'est que ça a été approuvé par la
commission de la concurrence américaines
des jeunes 8 ans donc la décision
d'intégrer l'acquisition de watson de
whatsapp exactement alors ce serait
revenir sur ce qui a déjà été approuvée
et sam est un espèce d'ambiance une
belle quand vous faites une conclusion
d'achat lé pas finalisées dans le fond
je vais donner un exemple en parallèle
dans le cas de disney +1 par exemple
dîner plutôt qu'acheter pixar ou marvell
ou lucasfilm
à une époque où il n'y avait pas encore
de streaming et qui voudraient revenir
et l'on voudrait démontrer par exemple
des fonctionnaires trop à lui
demanderait de revenir sur la vente de 6
en licence
c'est un peu le même principe j'ajoute à
ce que instagram au moment de la vente à
10 en 2012 est un pot du tout ce qu'elle
est aujourd'hui il y avait treize
employés 7 à 2% des utilisateurs
autorisés prodige et tv pas de riez pas
de possibilité d'achat pas de messagerie
pas d'algorithmes pas une exigence
artificielle et on a connecté dans le
fond sur cette application la
l'infrastructure de facebook qui
contient justement les algorithmes mais
aussi tout le modèle de gestion des
publicités de et de droit commun qu est
ce que c'est que ce serait difficile à
détricoter bruno se faire c'est souvent
la coquille vide alors en vain la valeur
ajoutée de facebook alors bruno ce
serait difficile à défaire tout ce qu'on
a construit qu'on a fait ne serait-ce
que sur le plan juridique mais sur le
plan de l'innovation gamin - ben faut
quand même se rappeler qu'en huit ans il
ya eu énormément de changements ces
résultats ont évolué est ce qu'on
voulait faire au départ faut se souvenir
aussi que facebook avait dit qu'il
allait laisser ces deux entités vivre de
leur côté est bon avec le temps on a vu
qu'ils ont tranquillement pas vite mais
rejet lundi à rome à un point tel que
mamie à l'allemande qui s'était opposé à
cette démarche en disant non nous on
veut en europe que ça soit trop réseau
qui soit vraiment distincts et qui n'a
pas un mélange des données des
algorithmes ça c'est une chose est de
l'autre côté aussi techniquement écoutez
ça peut fonctionner la preuve c'est que
vous avez un réseau très performant
comme secteur qui a son propre
algorithme et qui a quand même un
presque bientôt un milliard
d'utilisateurs donc ça se fait
techniquement ça se fête du travail
c'est messin sera conséquent avec la
distension moi j'ai l'impression qu'on
va se retrouveront les on pourrait
presque on pourrait pas bruno se
retrouver dans une saga comme on a connu
avec microsoft où on a quand on a
tellement contester les pratiques
anti-concurrentielles de microsoft
pendant des décennies
bah écoutez moi je peux vous dire je
l'avais celui cette histoire là mais je
peux vous dire que c'est pas le vent ce
qui ce qui va arriver faut savoir que le
service du contentieux de facebook est
très puissant ils seront très
convaincants ils vont aller chercher des
alliés pour prouver finalement que ce qu
on y est en train de leur demander c'est
pas mal trop gros et là évidemment on va
argumenter que maintenant facebook
instagram whatsapp c'est utilisé par des
milliards de personnes sur la planète
que ce serait faire du tort à l'ensemble
de l'humanité
si on devait d'état chez ses partisans
alors probablement que on va s'entendre
sur quelque chose de différent qui va
être moindre mais tout de même qui va
devoir faire réfléchir
facebook par rapport à son comportement
et de la façon qu'elle utilise son parc
si vous voulez ou son armada de réseaux
sociaux est il normal nelly que nous
soyons des milliards sur une seule
plateforme on dirait que notre vie
tourne autour de facebook est ce que
facebook écrase la concurrence
en fait c'est pas que facebook écrase
justement la concurrence parce que c'est
pas on s'en sert pas de façon
malveillante pour empêcher les gens ont
le choix
les gens sont sur facebook à cause de l'
avantage que ça représente
et lorsque je vous dirais c'est que bien
sûr plus une compagnie est un étonnement
nettement la pole plus à l'est les
moyens d'être concurrentiel est bon on
peut on peut se dire justement que c'est
pas c'est pas ils ont juste pour les
autres entreprises
mais par exemple mais je me mets du côté
du citoyen les citoyens lui a vraiment
un avantage à utiliser ces plateformes
le surtout que à travers les années
facebook a mis en place des quelques
barrières de protection pour les
citoyens parce qu'un manque wholesale en
amérique du nord mark la grande de
d'encadrement alors ne serait ce que
pour compris la désinformation contre et
l'a1 en ligne protéger le processus
électoral il ya vraiment plusieurs
mécanismes qui ont été mis en place en
ce moment et qui n'existe pas
nécessairement sur les autres
plateformes pas de manière aussi
performant alors le fait de justement
démantelé et de faire en sorte que ces
barrières aussi espèce de mur de
protection le ne soit plus en place mais
ça peut on encore plus vulnérables le
contrat
bruno pour revenir sur une partie de
votre question c'est sûr que pour la
concurrence c'est difficile de vivre
dans un écosystème où vous avez un
joueur aussi important que facebook
sachant que ils ont une habitude lorsque
évidemment ils ont ralenti les
acquisitions parce qu'ils savaient
qu'ils étaient regardés mais quand vous
êtes un joueur comme secteurs comme la
snap shot qui sont les deux réseaux qui
essaient de faire concurrence ou du
moins essayer de prendre une partie du
marché systématiquement lorsqu'il ya
quelque chose d'intéressant qui est créé
chez eux qu'on veut faire de
l'innovation si ça fonctionne le
moindrement bain et quelques mois après
facebook la reprend sous une autre forme
est assez similaire est très inspiré à
défaut de pouvoir l'acheter
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut stopper
facebook est ce qu'il faut si on a
démonté le page facebook
est-ce qu'il faut empêcher de facebook
de faire de nouvelles acquisitions nelly
moi je pense que c'est pas là dessus
qu'il faut focus et surtout avec les
arguments qui sont mentionnés là par
cette poursuite là où on veut protéger
les données protéger les consommateurs
si c'est vraiment ce qu'on veut faire
c'est plutôt du côté de la
réglementation je ne pense pas qu'il
faut démanteler facebook je pense qu'il
faut réglementer les gars femmes en
général il faut réglementer l'internet
pour justement s'assurer de ce qu'on
peut faire avec les données comme un
ratage la vie privée et c'est là en ce
moment en démantelant facebook à qui ça
sert vraiment je voudrais ce qu ils
savent eux de venir trois petites tapes
toquin grande histoire je pense certaine
que ça sinon le consommateur d'aucune
façon renault perdant même sens que
nelly à savoir que je pense que ce qui
est beaucoup plus important
qui est ce qui va affecter tout le monde
tous les joueurs dans l'industrie c'est
d'avoir un gendarme un peu comme on le
fait en europe avec des lois qui ont des
dents et qui s'assure donc d'assurer la
protection de la vie privée des citoyens
des utilisateurs qui ça que ce soit fait
aux états unis mais à la limite ou si
quelqu'un nada plus emboîté le pas et de
faire la même chose
bruno guglielminetti nelly brière merci
pour cette discussion ce soir bonne
soirée pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne i cirdi